louis louis how you doing bro
how you doing can you hear me yeah so
the question here is
uh there's something i noticed that
happened to me many times there are
many ladies that only talk to you when
they need a favor
and for some reason i always fall how
could i so
you're basically talking about beta
bucks if
she's not calling you to bang
then she's calling you for something
else uh
yeah the thing is i'm look i've been
into this of self-improvement and all of
this stuff of
let's say um uh
converting myself into an alpha you know
uh trying to improve myself hitting the
gym
hitting the the the saving
and investing and all that stuff you
know
the thing is uh since the quarantine
started and
we cannot because i'm in college we can
go to that social place let's say
um many girls have been
hitting me up like to talk what do they
ask you for
the thing is that they don't just come
and ask it
they come like to talk with me and they
talk with me like for a week
two weeks sometimes a month and then
when they ask me for a favor i just help
them because i
think of myself like uh um
how to say without without sound like a
meme
so are you familiar with alan roger
curry
no no i haven't heard about that he
wrote a book called mode one and one of
the things he talks about in the book
is sexual attention versus non-sexual
attention
when you look at women what do you think
you want to play a game of chess with
them you want to talk about politics
or you want to smash
uh i haven't actually made that question
to myself
what was the name of the of the book
mode 1
moto 1 mode m-o-d-e one
oh thank you but but answer my question
like when you look at a woman
what are you looking at her for
i like to meet people like to uh
make friends like me no no no no no no
no
no no you make friends with men you
don't make friends with women
that's part of your problem is you're
setting yourself up to be placed into
the friend zone
women are beauty objects to men men
are success objects to women that's what
they're looking at men
as right what can i get from this guy
that's you know that's what we were
talking about from the beginning was
fault's law right yeah i don't know if
you're on at the beginning but
that's what they're looking at man as is
they are a utility
right and in exchange they exchange
their beauty and their sexuality for
that
so you can't be looking at women like to
meet people or to become
friends you're basically setting
yourself up to friend zone yourself
every single time
and what you think is you're going to be
so good at friend zoning yourself
that her panties are going to fly off
and her bra is going to fly off in the
other direction and she's going to jump
your bones
and it doesn't work that way bro women
women have girlfriends and boyfriends
and if you're not banging
if you're not intimate with her then
guess what you're her girlfriend so
you're gonna be the emotional tampon
that she's gonna cry on
you're gonna be the guy that she calls
upon when chad thundercock smashes her
and doesn't call her back
you're gonna be the guy that she calls
on when she needs to move from one house
to another house or to pack boxes or to
pick up heavy you know stuff like
that don't
be that guy but that applies to every
woman even the ones that i don't want to
smash
all women
what what kind of friendship are you
going to get out of a woman
i don't have any female friends
again if i'm if i'm talking to a chick
it's because
we're either smashing or it's because
we're going to smash
so if i don't want a banger i don't want
i i don't get it the whole
the whole concept of alan roger curry's
sexual attention versus non-sexual
attention is
you want her sexual attention so open
the frame of the conversation
open the dialogue with everything that
you do with her
and build it around you want sexual
attention and if she starts like
limiting that and like no i don't want
you know that from you i just want to be
friends
cool i don't want any more friends i got
lots of friends
if you want some friends go find another
friend i think you're hot and i want a
bang
right like you can actually be that
direct
that's one of the things he talks about
in his book is his direct approach to
dating
the other thing that you got to do bro
is you got to clean up your look like
fix your hair
looks messy and stuff you got to get a
nice style going on with it
you know like you can clean that up
right
okay that's something that you have
control of so
like you have to understand that women
are going to judge you based on your
appearance
you just can't nice guy your way into
her pants like you can't be
that shoulder to cry on and expect her
to want to jump your bones they don't do
that that's not how women operate
yeah i know that anyhow
cool yeah thank you all right start with
that man
talk to you soon
you